repenti ni shawinigan québec
saint-anselme warwick longueuil on est
allé demander des électeurs québécois
adam est ce qu'on peut vous déranger
deux secondes ce qu'il pense du projet
de loi qui interdit le port des signes
religieux aux employés de l'état en
position d'autorité et les réactions
vont de je respecte le droit de religion
tout le monde a
on est chez nous puis gad on marche
d'une façon qui respecte et nous ce
débat là sur la question du port des
signes religieux vous en pensez quoi
maltais monsieur legault y a dix qui va
train de nous voir pour ça je suis
d'accord avec lui machin immigrés ok
j'ai d'origine française
je pense que quand tu es un immigrant tu
sais quand invités dans une maison tu
dois de respecter les us et coutumes des
gens qui t'accueille la religion je
pense que c'est une affaire personnelle
[Musique]
au québec au delà de tous les débats
musulmans catholiques aux autres ce
qu'on veut c'est que dans livres dans
les lieux notamment à une position
d'autorité ce soit clair on veut une
société laïque ça comme à saint paul et
ses affaires comme ça que rester neutre
auteur balsa phares comme ça je
comprends ce jeu c'est un accord avec ça
mais je pense que le gouvernement de la
cac semble aller rapidement peut être un
désert dans la population mais
je pense qu'il faut pas aller trop
rapidement des fois pour les changements
ça que la grogne
moi je suis très bien mais je ne le
montre pas c'est plus moi je le fais
chez moi et l'église où j'en suis par
contre que la personne montre c'est son
côté spirituel toujours en respectant
l'environnement
il ya tellement d'autres choses plus
importantes à régler séparer l'état de
la religion c'est tout à fait d'accord
ça va faire un cirque eu une femme
musulmane ne pourra pas être prof c'est
à la fois son voile mais que son mari
qui tous musulmans pour les directeurs
d'école beau pot vers l'égalité où je
pense que je serais pour tous les jeux
n'est pas le seul à l'école je pense que
pour ses produits photo la laïcité pour
tenir l audio religieux pas plus au
gouvernement non plus le crucifix pour
moi c'est un des volets qui a pas de
grande importance
c'est je trouve que tout le monde doit
sa religion ça vous préoccupe la
question du policing vives et les
chevilles on est à court d'enseignants
pour vos futures moi mais tout porte le
voile
alors que tessa les verriers à leurs
qualités d'enseignant et moi je pense
que le bouillet bien neigé lepreau
présentement ils pas allés à l'extrême
c'est pas parce que tu portes un signe
religieux que nous sommes nécessairement
se voit faire du prosélytisme et au
québec
fort et puis parce que moore qui
explique à nos régions natales pour ce
qui est des enseignants je trouve que
c'est pas correct interdit parce qu'il y
en a que y ont passé des années à
l'université à étudier nous nous sommes
débarrassés de la mainmise de la
religion sur notre vie politique au
québec et pour éviter que n'importe
quelle autre religion prennent vient
combler le vide c'est maintenant qu'il
faut faire parce que les gens sont
libres de porter le voile n'est pas je
ne comprends pas qu'on va vraiment
pourquoi ce débat